on vient de déguster du caramel du
bénéfice
on a été voir les plantes là bas c'est
un moment de bonheur on échappe
la société actuelle à ses dires ce côté
négatif il ya de la couleur il ya de la
vie c'est vraiment un moment on se sent
mieux
lucas et joël font partie des dix mille
curieux à participer à la quatrième
édition d'esprit jardin à versailles ces
samedis et dimanches 2 et 3 avril
esprit jardin un jardin éphémère
construit en deux jours qui met à
l'honneur plus de 70 exposants
aujourd'hui le jardin est une fête des
plantes qui a beaucoup évolué au départ
c'était une fête qui était organisée
pour
les habitants du quartier de verse de
saint louis et aujourd'hui c'est une
fête des plantes qui regroupe environ 80
exposants qui sont choisis pour leurs
produits de qualité et pour faire venir
les le public à la fois de versailles et
de la région une façon de s'initier aux
jardins dans la ville et à la ville dans
le jardin cette année le thème retenu
pour le jardin éphémère réalisée par la
direction des espaces verts de
versailles et l art de la promenade
l'occasion de s'associer avec le potager
du roi pour une présentation gratuite
la thématique la promenade la promenade
au jardin nous semblait à la fois un
sujet a attiré du monde chez nous mais
aussi un sujet deux paysages
d'appréhension de paysages de comment
est-ce qu'on visite les espaces donc un
sujet à la fois pour le potager du roi
le site et ainsi j'ai pour l'éco
nationale supérieure du paysage à c'est
très important parce que ça permet de
rassembler beaucoup de commandes de
commerçants d'artisans fin d'article
terre voilà en plus on a énormément de
choix
c'est très vivant convivial un week-end
rythmée par différents ateliers et
animations qui en ont fait un rendez
vous pris depuis maintenant quatre ans
par le public parmi les curieux 60% de
versailles et et 40% de spécialistes
jardin